[Applaudissements]
j'accueille maintenant Stéphane Guillon
mesdames messieurs
bonsoir
avez Stéphane Guillon pour la semaine de
Stéphane Guillon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors alors une fois n'est pas coutume
Thierry je voudrais rendre hommage à la
clairvoyance de Nicolas Sarkozy qui
avait qualifié il y a quelques semaines
PPDA et Arlette Chabot de trop daté trop
mou trop vu et bien j'ai bien regardé il
a raison
municipale vicash doraso s'engage aux
côtés de Bertrand Delanoë attention si
un ancien du PSG veut vous aider à
gagner quelque chose
méfiance méfiance
de la Noé rêve style d'être première
dame de France un mimétisme avec Carla
Bruni qui laisse perplexe
[Applaudissements]
urbanisme 300 millions d'euros pour le
lifting d'une tour à la défense le
record de régime est battu
la chanteuse qui perd deux records cette
semaine puisque Ségolène Royal a déclaré
51000 euros de frais de maquillage pour
sa campagne
c'est comme ça
société après la disparition de Louis
cazena il ne reste plus qu'un seul poilu
protestation de Demis Roussos qui veut
être comptabilise
[Musique]
droit d'inventaire en mai 68 Michel
Drucker aurait crié CRS SS et jeter des
pavés si vous possédez un cliché de
Michel jetant un pavé écrivez-nous ça
nous intéresse
la garde-robe de Mitterrand aux enchères
non celle de Sarkozy est invendable
peut-être pour une soirée déguisée et
encore je vois pas ce que
[Applaudissements]
krach boursier titre Libé eh faut rien
exagéré les Bourses mondiales se
redressent toujours
excepté celle d'Orlando là il y a rien à
faire
[Applaudissements]
c'est gratuit
c'est mieux tu travailles comme ça
sport pour s'entraîner les sauteurs à ce
qui finlandaise se font propulser dans
les airs par un partenaire la technique
la technique du lancer sa méthode que
Brice hortefeuille est pas pensé pour
envoyer les en papier
[Applaudissements]
théâtre dans le spectacle de Jérôme
Savary Arielle Dombasle est habillé en
lapin même si c'était pas du tout
chasseur ça démange
people à propos de Cécilia le magazine
Gala titre et si elle était la nouvelle
Diana c'est possible il faut juste
dégager le port de l'Allemagne pour
trouver un chauffeur bourré et louer une
Fiat Uno
voilà
[Applaudissements]
et on passe au récompenses le prix du
plus gros fayot revient Julien Clerc qui
a demandé à Carla Bruni de lui écrire
ses chansons
Julien Clerc mitterrandiste sous
Mitterrand villepiniste sous Villepin
Sarkozy
et on termine par un fait divers
particulièrement triste
il m'est arrivé souvent de plaisanter
sur un crash d'avion une vieille qui se
fait trucider ou un bébé congeler mais
aujourd'hui je voudrais vous alerter sur
le cas de Nicole Borgnon
excusez-moi qui a glissé sur une frite
dans un fast-food et qui s'est cassé la
jambe voilà parfois s'il vous plaît
parfois l'émotion nous submerge à la
semaine prochaine merci merci beaucoup
merci
[Applaudissements]
Guillon
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu